well good morning councillors and
members of the public
and members of staff
to clear the meeting open
very good declaration of
interest any changes to that
thank you move on to the minutes
of infrastructure services committee
meeting held
on a on
june 2021
yes i will remove the minutes and the
recommendations
and close within i'll second that your
worship
moved and seconded your discussion
questions
put it to the voter all in favor say aye
against carried
minutes of the infrastructural services
committee held on the 1st of june 2021
you just move those your worship you
just
just moved through those minutes oh
moved that the sorry about that there's
quite a lot happening at the moment
um that the re recommendations from the
infrastructural services committee
meeting
held on the 1st of june 2021 be
confirmed
um you wish if i have moved those
recommendations to council
that's 7.2
which ones are those
excluded
you wish if i'm happy to move that we go
into public excluded session with the
exception of mr mckenzie and mr grant
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the bank
on the issue of uh moving into public
excluder i have some reservations about
why we would take a
decision about a commercial property
into uh into public
exclusion i feel it should be in an open
session
just wanted to express that okay
any further questions or discussion on
that
i guess it's an amendment is it
counsellor clerk are you moving an
amendment yes i'll
i'll move an amendment that stays on an
open session
move on to the amendment then
anyone wish to speak to that
put it to the very top and play worship
the amendment you worship you haven't
asked for a second after the amendment
oh second for the amendment
it lapsed for one of a second then i
guess
so we're back to the original motion
any further discussion on that
i'll put it to the vote all in favor say
aye
aye and like it recorded i was supposed
to worship you
any other counselor wish to have that
vote recorded
thank you move on
to the original submission
let the public be excluded put it to the
version and they have to say aye
against i don't know
if you've already taken that vote
we have already voted on that your
worship
general subject of such a matter be
consented so you want to go
into just
beg to the original agenda is that what
people are voting for
you worship we have already voted um to
go into public excluded
and that is why councillor clark asked
for his opposition
to be recorded because the vote was
taken
you help us out on that we just moved
under publicly
and apparently it's been past that the
public being
excluded so thanks very much for your
presence everyone
just a point of order you worship aren't
we now reading out the reasons
for the public exclusion to conform with
uh requests from oia and
yeah oh an audit
that's what everyone's doing
i think if it's voted
for and there's no vote against
i've a feeling we go back to the
original version
respectfully your worship um they
the vote has been cast that we do go
into public
excluded and it resulted in
the motion passing the the reasons for
that um
for us to go into public excluded at
this time was so
that the committee could carry on
without prejudice or disadvantage any
negotiations
including commercial and industrial
negotiations
and that is the case at which we at this
council is now resolved to do
so it would now be appropriate for you
to
request that the public take leave so
that we can
conduct that business yes i thought
that's where we're at
yeah anyone else want to put their name
down
i'll put it to the vote oh it's been
voted off
oh well thank you very much for your
presence everyone members of the public
you